Hey everyone, this is Ryan here and welcome back to our prosthodontic series.
In this video, we're going to unpack the idea and the concepts behind Pontic and Connector Design.
So we've already talked about the components of a bridge.
Just to review the abutment is the tooth to which the bridge attaches.
So these two abutment teeth have been properly prepped to receive the crowns of a bridge.
The retainer refers to the crown that actually attaches to the abutment.
So these two would be considered retainers.
The Pontic is the fake tooth between abutments and the connector connects the retainer to the Pontic.
So usually you'll have a Pontic or multiple Pontics between retainers.
But there are cases if you have what's called a cantilever bridge, you can have just one retainer
and one or more Pontics attached to it.
So you can have different combinations of these elements.
So let's focus on the Pontic and the different designs that these fake teeth can have.
So the first one is the hygienic Pontic, also sometimes called the sanitary Pontic.
And this is a cross section or side view of this design.
And notice the space between the Pontic and the ridge.
So the hygienic Pontic is used primarily in the posterior mandible region.
It offers great hygienic capability and hence the name.
And the reason for that is because there's space between the Pontic and the ridge.
So you can fit a round brush between this.
You can fit super floss easily and you can keep food and other things from getting caught
between the bridge and the gingiva.
So that's the main benefit of this design.
However, they're poor aesthetics because you have a pretty big gaping hole between the
tooth and the gums.
And you need to have enough video, which is a vertical dimension of occlusion or restorative
space, meaning there has to be enough room to afford this extra two millimeters of space.
Otherwise you're going to have to make this tooth, or the Pontic, very, very thin.
And when you make something in dentistry too thin, it's prone to breaking fracture.
So the second Pontic design is the saddle Pontic or the ridge lap Pontic.
And this one you really should never use.
And it's because like a saddle on a horse, it firmly wraps around the ridge here.
And so there's no way you could fit some kind of brush underneath that and keep it clean.
And it's very bad for hygiene for that reason.
So a lot of things can get caught under there and it's very hard to keep the area clean.
It can lead to periodontal problems around the abutment teeth and eventual failure of
the bridge.
So this one is not often used and in fact you should never use it.
The next design we have is the conical Pontic design.
This one is reserved mostly for molars.
And it's similar to the hygienic design but marginally better aesthetics.
So the conical design you can see has a conical shape to it from the side view.
And instead of having this space, it has just one little point of contact at the ridge.
So this enables you to slide a brush under here.
There's some give of the soft tissue so you can put a brush or some super floss underneath
the bridge and keep it clean.
So this one's pretty good.
It has some pros and maybe it's not as hygienic as the hygienic Pontic but it still offers
ability for cleanseability.
Alright so we talked about the ridge lap or saddle design, this is a modified form of
it.
So we call it the modified ridge lap Pontic.
This is reserved mostly for anterior Pontics and it offers really good aesthetics.
So this is a look at the modified ridge lap.
You can see instead of wrapping around the buckle and lingual portion of the ridge, it's
only sort of half way in contact with the buckle part of the ridge and the lingual part
is kind of more like the conical design where it peels off and isn't firmly attached and
right up against the soft tissue.
So this enables you to have some cleanseability, not as much as the conical or hygienic designs
because there's a little bit more contact there.
But you're talking about an anterior tooth.
So aesthetics is certainly a consideration.
So you don't obviously want to have a big gaping hole here and even just a little point
contact isn't going to look very natural.
So having this profile contact the soft tissue, you can actually make it appear as if it's
coming out of the gingiva and make it a pretty aesthetic look.
But even better for aesthetics and the most superior aesthetic design has to be the ovate
pontic.
This is used really only for anterior teeth and it provides superior aesthetics because
you actually embed the pontic into a little divot in the soft tissue and the ridge that
you make.
So this one actually requires a minor surgery.
So you actually make this space so that the pontic can go into that little divot and it
actually appears and it's coming out of the soft tissue just as a natural tooth would be
emerging from the gingiva.
We call that the emergence profile when a tooth is coming out of the gingiva in a certain
way to make it appear very natural.
So this one has the best aesthetics for that reason but it requires surgery and the proper
dimensions of a dental ridge in order to make that phenomenon look and appear natural and
aesthetic.
Alright, so those are the five pontic designs I wanted to talk to you about.
But we also have the certain connector designs that I want to mention.
The connector is connecting the retainer to the pontic.
So for connector designs we don't have five to choose from.
We only have really two main categories, those being rigid and non-rigid.
So the rigid connector is either cast in one piece or soldered together.
So if we look at this image here, these connectors we can think of as being rigid.
You can't break them apart, they're stuck together, either cast all in one piece of
metal or these have been soldered together so you can't remove them from each other.
The non-rigid connector design is shown right here in this image where you can actually
put them together like puzzle pieces and take them apart.
So this male female kind of design is indicated when it's impossible to obtain a common path
of insertion between the abutments.
So we see a pretty good example of this in this image because the path of insertion is
along the long axis of the prep.
So that would be about the path of insertion for this one.
Because this tooth is tipped and let's just say you can see how the prep has been made
along the long axis of this tooth, the path of insertion for that crown would be at about
that angle.
So now we have a discrepancy between this very up and down seating and this sort of oblique
path of insertion.
So if we had this all as one big piece with 1, 2, 3 rigid connectors, probably we might
not even be able to seat that bridge because of the discrepancy between the path of insertions.
So if this is an issue then we pull out the non-rigid connector design in order to first
we can seat this one and then since this male connector can slide into this female connector
in a very up and down path of insertion then it's in line with this path of insertion and
we can fit the bridge in two steps, putting this crown in first and then followed by this
bridge component second.
So that's the use of having a rigid and non-rigid connector design and connectors for porcelain
fuse to metal bridges as a sort of guideline should have a minimum of about 3mm of height.
This is so that you have enough strength of the connector so that it doesn't fracture.
Of course if you could afford to have more than that, that's great because increasing
the connector height would increase the strength of the connector due to cervical occlusal
reinforcement.
And by cervical occlusal reinforcement I just mean the vertical dimension from cervical
to occlusal, the thicker that is, the less likely it is to fracture.
Alright thanks so much for watching everyone, I really appreciate all the support, please
stay tuned for the next video in our fixed prosthodontic series, thanks so much for watching
and I'll see you all next time.